par ailleurs vous portez atteinte à la
parole publique avec des chiffres faux
et des éléments de langage sophistiqués
destinées à perdre votre auditoire cela
témoigne d'un manque préoccupant de
sincérité vous avez illustré cette
insincérité avec le psychodrame des 1200
euros de pension minimale il a fallu
qu'un économiste Michael Zemmour perce
le barrage de vos éléments de langage
pour dévoiler sur une radio publique à
une heure de grandes d'écoute le biais
que vous utilisez pour affirmer que
votre réforme porterait la pension
minimale à 1200 euros même se
dévoilement tonitruant ne vous a pas
convaincu de cesser les infox il a fallu
qu'un député socialiste fasse valoir ses
prérogatives de vice-président de la
mission d'évaluation et de contrôle de
la sécurité sociale à l'Assemblée au
siège de la sécurité sociale pour
obtenir les authentiques évaluations
chiffrées des effets de la réforme des
retraites
nous savons donc maintenant que ce ne
sont pas 40000 personnes chaque année
qui passeront le cap des 85% du SMIC et
que seul 20 000 retraités au mieux
franchiront le seuil des 1200 euros
pourtant annoncer
je me permets maintenant de vous
suggérer de prendre le temps d'un peu de
pédagogie auprès du président de la
République puisqu'il a très
explicitement démontré qu'il ne saisit
pas le fonctionnement du minimum
contributif si le président de la
République veut cette réforme des
retraites mais qu'il ne la comprend pas
il se trouve que nous avec les Français
nous la comprenons mais nous n'en
voulons pas
[Musique]